false presupposition you are
presupposing that you know the story of
Jesus you're presupposing that what the
New Testament says about Jesus is
reliable I'm not ignoring your question
your question contains a false
presupposition I don't accept the
premise of your question you have to
verify the premise of your question so
that's why in response I asked you if
the Book of Mormon was to write was to
have a prophecy of the future and then I
come centuries later as Anonymous author
for the sake of argument like you
accepted and write stories perfectly in
line with what the Book of Mormon says
would that make my book and the Book of
Mormon both reliable and accurate answer
that question Avery because that
question is built because you have your
question has a false
presupposition I have to you can't what
do you call it you can't ask questions
built upon false
presuppositions okay I'll answer your
question about the crucifixion later
answer that question very simply if the
book of Mor you okay guys for all the
people calling me slow and I'm not
answering I directly answer deal with
his question his question Contin to F
presupposition so Avery answer the
question if the Book of Mormon
prophesizes the future and I come
centuries later writing a story
perfectly lined with what the Book of
Mormon says as an anonymous author would
that make my book in The Book of Mormon
reliable please answer okay so God L
because again I'm going to have a time
to answer if anybody interrupts them I'm
going to drop them you know I don't know
appreciate it brother so um so Ramsey is
doing a good job of trying to run away
and avoid the actual question ladies and
gentlemen but it's okay uh Ramsey a a
prophecy that comes true is rooted in
the historicity and the fact thereof
that it came true that it came to pass
so when you're saying uh if somebody in
the Book of Mormon predicts something
and then someone comes later and writes
the copies the story down as if it
happened does that make it true if it's
not based in history no it does not this
is why I asked you Ramsey and here's
your chance to answer this question do
the majority of historians agree that
Jesus was crucified under Pontius Pilate
in the first century yes or no okay I'll
I'll answer that um the answer is no we
don't even have any evidence for the
existence of Jesus uh historically for
example uh there was this guy named I
forgot how to say his name but it's t a
z i t us he the sources of his
information he doesn't uh give us
anything there was also some some what
do you call
it some
problems do want me to a are you done
speaking Yeah I wanted you to answer
that question please no no but have you
made are you done speaking am I time to
speak now or are you gonna continue well
I'm gon to continue uh based off your
answer we have we have to we have to
finish though finish and then I'll speak
yeah that's that that's that's my
question so that I can you know build my
point all right so it's not a one word
answer I'm going to speak for a minute I
mean if you well I mean go go if you
want to I'm I'm fine I'm fine just yeah
just answer elabor majority of
historians who base their their
conclusions off continuities and based
their sources of sorry their conclusions
based upon the only sources we have
available which are Christian sources
right they quote the New Testament
however here's a so so a couple points
one majority of historians who are
secular Bas Bas their conclusions based
upon a couple things first of all
continuities based upon the continuity
that Romans crucified lots of people and
that we have sources that tell us a man
named Jesus was crucified sure yes
majority of secular historians believe
that a man was crucified the problem is
Avery that's not what the book of Isaiah
is prophesizing supposedly not just some
Tom Dick and Harry named Jesus was
crucified it's that supposedly the Lamb
of God was crucified for the sins of the
world yeah atheists believe Christ was
crucified Jews believe Christ was Cru
crucified that's fine the question of
whether a guy was crucified is not what
you're proving here the question is or
sorry the prophecy is not just that some
guy was crucified it was that the Lamb
of God right he was cut off supposedly
what's the what does the prophecy
supposedly say it was what it call it he
was kill killed for the sins for the
sins of many I forget the exact words of
the prophecy but nonetheless basically
according to you teach te is that you
know he died for the sins of the world
he was cut off from the land of the
living for the sins of the world yeah
that's the prophecy it's not that just
some guy just some guy in the future is
gonna die otherwise we can claim anyone
anyone crucified fulfills that prophecy
so Avery let me ask that question let me
ask let me ask that question to you does
anyone who C anyone Cru being crucified
fulfill that
prophecy it's specific to Jesus and and
you you helped me out you you actually
you actually helped me out wa no wait
wait rsey wait Ry no notice wait rsy
slow down dude notice how I was I was
but neither was I but you took a minute
to to talk you took a turn you gave me
that minute to talk no but but hold on
but hold on though what how's this gonna
go Ramsey you asked I asked you a
question so that I can build my point
you said no I need to answer fully I'm
gonna talk for a minute so you just
asked so so so you did that yo yo Zeno
please
yeah it's okay so you did that so you
just asked me a question talked you gave
your turn you talked and then you just
asked me a question so now I'm going to
take my turn okay fine go ahead go ahead
I appreciate it so you don't even
realize how you just helped me you just
admitted that according to historians
Jesus was crucified under Pontius Pilate
and according to Isaiah it talks about
the crucifixion of Jesus it isn't just
that the New Testament authors are
recording are matching a story that they
find uh in in the Old Testament they're
recording history now let me let me let
me ask like let's put it into this
perspective like for again so one you
admitted that historians agree that
Jesus was crucified under Pontius Pilate
now here's my question to you what is
the primary source what is the primary
source that they use to come to the
conclusion that Jesus was crucified
under Pontius Pilate what's the primary
source Ramsey okay so you seem to not
know how history Works history is built
on a scale of probability historians
will not claim excuse me let me speak
historians cannot claim with certainty
anything in history the only thing they
could claim is that Jesus Christ PC upon
him they would claim probably existed
and was probably crucified because
that's what the sources we have tell us
but here's the problem Avery do do new
test sorry Testament do uh historians
take the New Testament as a historically
reliable source of information for
example for example Avery answer this
question do what call it do historians
consider the resurrection to be a
historical event answer that question
I'll answer after this uh ramsy you you
skip you skip my question I'm gonna
answer after you ski my question ramsy I
asked
you I would just like to put I did
answer I did answer I did I would just
like to put it out there exactly I just
like to put it out there we have no
historical evidence for the existence of
Jesus that is um that is a well-known
fact anybody who does their you know um
worth of research would know that there
isn't really any strong evidence there's
the existence of
Christians um however there's not the
founder which is Jesus Christ he said
that I didn't answer his question was
what source be quiet be quiet no it's
not about me being quiet it's my turn
I'm repeting your question I'll I I'll
give my question I'll give my question
it's my turn you finished his question
was be Qui stop bro I'm repeating your
question for God's sake stop what you
call stop manifesting I don't need you
to repeat my question it's my turn to
speak I'm gonna repeat an answer calm
down it's my it's my turn to speak
please if I can you like the sound of
your voice you just like the sound of
your voice I think that's projection it
doesn't work here that's projection it
doesn't work here question projection it
doesn't what is the primary source be
quiet what was question was what was the
primary source of the life of Jesus
Christ he had his turn to speak it's my
turn to speak now your question to
answer it what are you talking about so
it's my turn to speak nowk want to
answer you don't want to answer I I I
want I want an answer after I get a
chance my my turn thank you you're just
going to repeat the question okay go
ahead on um host what's going on bro
what are you
doing
look question wasse dude stop being so
hyper you
shouldn't can you relax rela no it's not
it's not logic relax tell Ry to relax
cuz he just
spoke relax
was okay guys does you not want to
answer those question why am I being
muted host host what is going on man
muted every hold on everyone please stop
please
okay please for the love of
Allah gonna
have why are you not telling him to be
quiet as I answer his question look look
yeah yeah okay I'm trying to be fair I'm
trying to you know you're not being fair
I okay I'm trying all right you're being
you're being fair when you let me speak
they don't think you're being fair
that's the that's their
problem I'm your question listen look
this this is what we're going to do host
if he doesn't answer the question we're
we're going to we're going to allow the
host to we're going to pack your ass up
and get on no why are you even up here
why are you even up here your question
have been done I could have been done no
it's my it's my turn very simple very
simple it's my turn to speak why is he
getting my turn to speak to answer
manifest keep manifesting keep
manifesting no problem host it's my turn
to speak I'm trying to answer your
question you asked what is wrong with
you can you decide can we just listen to
The Host
pleas then I I'll give you a minute each
this is wild he's getting another minute
this is wild you wanted me to answer
your question what the hell this is
crazy I know it's crazy you're gon get
an answer to your question his question
earlier was what do do test sorry what
do Scholars use what do historians use
to say Jesus was crucified I mentioned
my question was the primary source
that's what I just oh for God's sake
okay the New Testament bro stop talking
logic stop manifesting yeah beautiful I
said or sorry the question was what do
historians use primarily to say Jesus
was crucified did I not mention the New
Testament is this guy death I swear this
guy the voice thank you thank you that's
enough I mentioned they thank you that's
enough then you gave the answer you
already answered you said you were just
answering let me finish you said you
were just answering you're done you're
done
tell me quiet tell me quiet okay the
problem is Avery you just said now
you're getting another now he's getting
another turn me the problem is
Avery let me finish be
quiet you said you answer my question
then you're going to shut up so now it's
my turn it's my turn now answer you
answered my question it's over answer up
let me finish my answer the problem is
Avery and this is something you know
that I know you know but you don't care
historians don't consider the New
Testament to be a reliable source of
information they quote it and they quote
various Christian beliefs that were
prevalent in the first century as
continuities as a part of the Historical
Method but they don't take the New
Testament itself as a reliable source of
information historians don't consider
the resurrection or Miracles or they
don't consider the New Testament to be a
reliable source of information so
appealing to the New Testament as the
quote unquote primary source of
information just because the Old
Testament mentions a a a crucified
person doesn't then verify everything in
the New Testament you have to verify the
authenticity and reliability of the new
testament which I know you can't Avery
which you're embarrassed by and yes
Christian scholarship openly admits that
the New Testament is not a perfect
source of information
ites it is an anonymous they are four
Anonymous documents you know that Avery
stop hiding you know that okay now now
you know every is gonna get to speak
please don't interrupt him if anybody
interrupts him I'm dropping it I had
enough I tried to be nice please be
consistent thank you host so so so
notice here and he got two chances to
speak he said he was going to answer my
question and that would be it but he
took that opportunity um and manipulated
the situation to go ahead and filibuster
some more and put himself in a deeper
hole Ramsey you're an embarrassment you
look can you mute up please yo yo this
is crazy like I I seriously the Panic is
insane dude relax Ramsey you literally
just gave me the discussion first you
admitted that according to historians
they agree that Jesus was crucified then
you just admitted out of your own mouth
out of your fast speaking mouth that the
primary source that they used to come to
this conclusion is the New Testament
while no notice how he's interrupting me
again he can't help
himself he can't help himself so these
are two things guys he admitted that
Jesus was crucified according to
historians and he also agreed that the
primary source that they use to conclude
that Jesus was crucified is the New
Testament while in the same breath he
then said that they don't take the New
Testament as a reliable source of
information are you dense how do you
contradict yourself in the same breath
like that dude thank you for this
discussion I I I appreciate you giving
me this every single time we talk so
what which is it is it is the do the do
the historians use the the New Testament
as the primary source or do they not but
you said that they do so is it reliable
for them or is it not how are they using
a source that they say is unreliable to
conclude that it as their primary source
the fact that Jesus was crucified by
pess Pilot in the first century you're
contradicting yourself all over the
place man you're a rookie at this here's
another thing too
Ry hold on getting gifts it's a little
loud here's another thing too Ramsey
that um that that you're failing to deal
with and you're failing to acknowledge
so now that we've
concluded your mods your mods muted me
it's it's crazy isn't it how they do
you're probably going to have to unmute
the or un mod the ones who keep muting
me host honestly it's probably going to
keep going like this but but this is how
it is so ramsy not only that do you have
to deal with it so with your admissions
you just admitted that the crucifixion
of Jesus is a historical fact and it is
historically reliable by virtue of the
New Testament according to Scholars now
again when now if you're trying to go
into the problem of the Resurrection
that is a a that they that's a
miraculous event now they don't have an
explanation we can argue for the
resurrection all day long but that's not
the subject here we can do that next but
the subject here is the historicity of
the New Testament and the events of
Jesus that the historians as you admit
it use as their primary source to say
that Jesus was crucified which then
supplements the point that Isaiah 53 is
a true prophecy of a historical event
that even you at admitted is historical
by the scholars uh admission thank you
okay can I speak
now okay there's a couple of false
equivocations Aver is making here number
one if historians utilize a source to
verify one event that doesn't then
therefore mean they conclude the New
Testament is reliable that's why I asked
the question a you can ask this question
when I'm done do New Testament sorry not
Testament do historians consider the
resurrection to be a historical event
the same Source you think that first of
all I never said said the historians
take it as reliable they don't you can
consider historical sources without
deeming them perfectly reliable and
authentic it's very simple guys do
historians consider the what do you call
it the resurrection a historical event
everyone answer the audience do
historians consider the resurrection to
be a historical event no they don't the
same New Testament teaches that but they
reject that so no they don't consider
the New Testament or reliable source of
information Avery you don't know how the
Historical Method Works historians base
their beliefs on continuities what they
do is they look at overall what people
were saying at the time what people were
believing and so they come to reasonable
conclusions well okay yeah what's what
it seemed like everyone around believed
he was crucified so yeah it's a pretty
reasonable thing to conclude he was
crucified and guess what this doesn't
actually contradict what the Quran says
the Quran says the people were boasting
we killed the Messiah Jesus the son of
Mary so this doesn't by any way let me
finish let me finish this doesn't by any
way prove your narrative Avery this in
fact actually goes perfectly line with
what the Quran says the Quran says
people thought he was crucified so you
showing me a bunch of Tom Dick and
Harry's who supposedly thought he was
crucified doesn't prove the entire
Narrative of the New Testament yes they
Ed the New Testament as evidence that
people believed he was crucified and
they accept based upon continuities that
yes probably you know R Rome was a place
the Roman Empire was a place people got
crucified seemed like everyone around
believed Jesus this guy named Jesus was
crucified that doesn't then verify the
New Testament as a whole as a reliable
source of information what have you been
sipping on what is wrong with you you
don't know how the Historical Method
Works you're but you're doing exactly
what the Quran says Avery you follow
nothing but conjecture the Old Testament
talks about a story the New Testament
you according I'll granted for the sake
of argument just for I'm not agreeing to
this but for the sake of argument I'll
Grant it the New Testament perfectly
agrees with it well you have to verify
the new test before you use that as
evidence and your evidence for that is
well historians say that a guy named
Jesus was crucified and because the New
Testament teaches that therefore the New
Testament is reliable what is wrong with
you what on God's green earth is wrong
with you Avery bro go back to the dance
floor honestly you're better off there
so B so let me just conclude with this
very simple very simple the claim you
made was that the Old Testament
prophesizes the story of Jesus that
claim is built upon a false and baseless
presupposition that the New Testament is
reliable showing us things that
historians agree with what it says
doesn't prove the New Testament is
reliable even if historians were to
agree which they do generally they
believe yeah some guy named Jesus was
crucified that's not what this prophecy
is your prophecy that you're trying to
prove is not that some Tom Dick and
Harry with the name Jesus was crucified
it's that the Son of God himself the
Lamb of God was killed for the sins or
un alive excuse me for the sins of the
world you're making so many false
equivocations and false presuppositions
because you need to Avery so I'm gonna
ask you this simple question Avery one
more time why do you sorry it's well
it's okay me phrase I'm gonna ask you a
simple question why do you believe the
New Testament is a reliable source of
information simply telling us that it
matches with what the Old Testament says
does not prove it as reliable you have
to prove that the authors were authentic
and reliable honest what's the what's
the answer why do you believe the New
Testament is
reliable if I could say if I could say
something before
this like here
um I had to first before we even go do
anything else I had to First think what
do the Jews think of this um because
again this was for them this was what
the uh what he was talking about so the
question is asked is this talking about
Jesus is talking about just you know one
single
person and this is the answer from a
Jewish website the book published by
chosen people distributed free to
thousands of Jewish Home part of a
million
dollar C second year and the use of
Isaiah Isaiah 53 the suffering servant
chapter has been consistently misquoted
by missionaries trying to claim that the
prophet Isaiah is speaking of Jesus and
fulfills the prophecies that he would
suffer for our sin I'm granting him for
the sake of argument so it doesn't
really there's no granting an AR we need
to have just like a conversation so
often what what are you talking about
he's right that's what I was clarifying
earlier that they misrepresented and I
was showing peace how they misrepresent
that argument why why are all these
people getting a chance to speak before
me this is crazy let let me guys let me
read please they often cite the fact
that the servant is singular and must
therefore be talking about the single
individual Jesus Al um though a
throughout analysis can not be given in
this limited space we have explor
important points
first book of
[Music]
Isaiah answer let me let me just read
this because we need to see you know
what did the Jews see about this um
first one must read the entire book of
Isaiah from an accurate Jewish
translation um it was written by Isaiah
who was a prophet
from 619 to 5 33 BCE in the original
text there was no chapter and breaks the
book has written in a fluid format and
therefore must read as a whole then in
so you will note that this chapter which
is known as the 47 Psalm actually begins
chapter 53 verse 13 when reading Isaiah
um and five text God often calls hisra
and Jacob the conversation he needs to
speak he needs to
respond his servant is the Jews believe
he was crucified come on
supp he's basically explain Isaiah 53 is
not about Jesus yeah this was this
just argument it doesn't matter he needs
to answer now come on what is this
missing
time forget everything I just
said app I appreciate it thank you guys
so much for finally letting me letting
me speak gonna forget and ignore
everything I said so so host just to
just to touch on what you're saying man
um because you're trying to appeal to
Jews who are trying to go against like
the Messianic ship of Jesus the
messiahship of Jesus um this is who your
Authority is so if you're saying that
they're right then you have to say
they're right about him you know guess
not being the Messiah since that's
you're saying that that's the authority
by which you're supposed to judge and
interpret the scriptures so um if that's
the case then Jesus is not for the
Messiah you should and you should reject
Islam why did you diver from my
conversation I asked him a question
question you want me to rep my question
I wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised if
you forgot I mean you spoke for I don't
know what you
said allow me at the end to debate him
on
the I remember
some I made multiple points to a you
made him forget all of them I can't
blame I I remember I remember you
mentioned the Historical Method I
remember you mentioned why oh your
question was why do I believe the New
Testament is reliable that's what that's
I mean yeah I built up to that but okay
yeah I you want to answer that so so I I
I'm GNA address what I what I remember
so you you mentioned the historical me
you said you me you mentioned the
Historical Method and you said that
historians judge things by continuity um
that's that's not all that entails the
the Historical Method um Ramsey so I'm
gonna read some of this the stuff that
of what the um Historical Method entails
so it entails independent and multiple
attestation which is similar with what
you said you're talking about continuity
right So a multiple attestation in and
independent sources it uh which are the
New Testament sources um uh Criterion of
embarrassment which is what you have in
the New Testament with the New Testament
authors claiming that they ran and were
cowards and even um you know went
against Jesus sometimes and rejected him
uh dismissing him can you drop can you
drop these wait can you drop these guys
can you wait wait one
second there's no need if he's gonna
drop anybody we're good goodness what
point what point are you trying to prove
right now just so I know what point are
you proving Historical Method that you
mentioned you mentioned you you
mentioned how the historians take things
by continuity you said I don't
understand what the Historical Method is
so I'm giving you this the Historical
Method okay so we have early attestation
um independent sources and and uh
multiple attestation you have the
Criterion of embarrassment which I
already mentioned how the disciples um
you know you know rejected Jesus ran
from Jesus you know were cowards right
you have you know so it's mentioning
their embarrassment there uh you also
have the Criterion of of coherence now
this one says this it says the Criterion
of coherence looks at the larger pattern
of Christ's historical circumstances and
a and attempts to determine whether a
specific event coheres with that pattern
if an event coheres with a larger
pattern then it is more likely to be
historical than not Scholars agree that
Christ's crucifixion coheres with other
known facts of his life uh most obvious
being that he clearly upset the Jewish
authorities by claiming to be the Divine
son of man this title was this title was
Christ's preferred self- reference
according to Dan Wallace
so don't drop me don't drop me bro he's
a troll man he's just trolling can you
just drop the troll I'm be quiet I don't
know why I keep
getting can you just can you just leave
it with me and ramsy on the on the pan
police is what all bro I just I just
want to stay up here with the why you
stressing like you got five kids bro
just run your life dog come on okay okay
I'm not I'm not I'm not
done what's that sound that coming from
yeah I'm addressing the things that you
said Ramsey and I didn't interrupt you
not I know is this I know I know but is
this to prove the New Testaments
reliable it's it's actually to refute
what you were saying about the
Historical Method and showing how you
just contradicted yourself yet again so
if you just let me continue please I
appreciate it so I'm showing you that
you don't know anything about the
historical method and what it entails
and how the New Testament according to
the scholars passes the new uh passes
the Historical Method with early
attestation multiple attestation
criteria of embarrassment and criteria
of coherence and so what you have is
according to the the scholars that you
even said one that they their primary
source on whether or not Jesus was
crucified that they can and how they
conclude that Jesus was crucified is the
New Testament that's what you admitted
earlier but at the same time in the same
breath you're saying that it's not
reliable it's not a reliable source when
they use it as a reliable source for the
crucifixion of Jesus that's that's the
conundrum that you're in and so then
when you say well they they they didn't
believe in the in the Resurrection The
Resurrection is a supernatural event so
this but this is what we have from the
from the from the even the liberal
Scholars they agree that the deciples of
Jesus thought that they saw a
resurrected Christ they agreed that
there was some some claim of a
resurrection going on they just don't
affirm that it happened because it's
supernatural now so since it's going
beyond the natural this is something
that the liberal Scholars who are
naturalist most Mo mostly who don't
believe in the Supernatural who don't
believe in miracles they reject this the
the resurrection but with no evidence
behind it no real reason behind it when
the ex when the resurrection is the best
explanatory evidence for set events so
you bringing up them not agreeing with
the resurrection has no bearing on
hysteric but on their bias towards the
supernatural that's why that's a red
herring and has nothing to do with what
we're talking about you're cooking
yourself you yourself admited I'm GNA
keep throwing your own words in your
face you yourself admitted one that the
historical Scholars agree that Jesus was
crucified number two you agreed that the
historical Scholars use the New
Testament as their
primary source for the fact not not that
it's a maybe not that it might have
happen let me let me just give you
because you keep saying you keep oh that
may be some guy C let me show you how
you're misrepresenting them here's James
here's James dun he says the crucifixion
is one of the two facts in the life of
Jesus that com that command almost
Universal ascent and that it ranks so
high on the the almost impossible to
doubt or to deny scale of historical
facts that's James Dunn here's Bart Man
Bart the crucifixion of Jesus by the
Romans is one of the most secure does
bman say maybe guys you know he says it
maybe no he says it's one of the most
secure facts we have about his life okay
scholar Luke Timothy Johnson agrees
saying the support for the mode of his
death its agents and perhaps its
co-agents is overwhelmingly Jesus faced
a trial before his death was condemned
and executed by crucifixion historian
ger lunaman finds that Jesus death as a
consequence of crucifixion watch this
ladies and gentlemen is
indisputable EXC excuse me hold on
excuse me excuse me excuse me I'm gonna
roast this don't I hope you do because
you're the one getting roasted I'm going
to turn you over
John Dominic cron says wait wait wait wa
excuse me excuse me why why am I being
interrupted why am I being interrupted
why I why am I being interrupted
seriously host what's going on here man
why do you keep bringing this troll up
hold on hold on hold God say you did go
on for a bit of time that's because they
did that's because you and rsy both went
on for a bit of time and are you guys
are you guys can speak
for am I being interrupted fact why am I
being interrupted host yeah hold on we
do fact check over here yeah that's fine
you can fact check on your
turn yeah no and no notice these these
cowards are muting me Guys these cowards
are muting me and these cowards are
interrupting me my check
timeart let me know what's going on host
see at the bottom you see at the bottom
look what it say look at these
cardians incling what is happening host
fact check time bro can we fact check
it's why are they interrupting me on my
turn
oh my goodness it's a x turn it's not AK
X's turn it's my turn to speak you you
lied you lied okay we see how we see we
see how this is going guys so guys since
he's it's over what is B basing off see
how they do he basing it off of
eyewitness testimony he's basing it off
of TAC don't lie and run he's basing it
off
ofus was tus there oh my God thank youan
youan let him run
let him run R let him run R very easy so
there we have it ladies and gentlemen we
have it as soon as they're getting
roasted as soon as they're getting
chopped up stirred up and cooked what
they have to do is they have to troll
they have to interrupt they speak for
five minutes a piece I finally get my
chance to speak and when they're in
trouble oh no it's it's it's DOI X's
turn oh oh it's it's it's the other
person's turn my my goodness guys well
how how much I mean we're we're we're
never goingon to get used to
this we're never gonna get used well
we're never gonna get tired of this is
what I'm gonna say we're never gonna get
uh surprised by this whenever they're on
the roast board whenever they're on the
grill they have to interrupt they have
to insult they have to Mock and as when
they're sizzling when they're getting
cooked and it's embarrassing for them
now for them for their life you know
it's a lot for them you know about 300
people watching it was absolutely
embarrassing this is what we have now
I'm I'm going just finish what I was
reading though why not let's go ahead
and finish what I was
reading he's talking about the
Historical
Method John donam MC crosson says that
it t that that he takes it is uh
absolutely for
granted it's absolutely for granted that
Jesus was crucified under Pontius pilot
it's absolute
scholar Paula Frederickson writes that
that the crucifixion is the single
strongest fact we have about
Jesus come on man the Jesus seminar and
we know who those people are no friends
of Jesus which uh so this is what they
say they say and these are a group of
Skeptics by the way guys a group of
Skeptics this is what they say um
they say that the crucifixion of Jesus
Christ is one indisputable fact from his
ministry so this is what happened Ramsey
admitted that historians agree that
Jesus was
crucified Ramsey admitted that
historians use the New Testament as
their primary source that Jesus was
crucified and the facts of his
life so what does this show this shows
that Isaiah
53 according to the Historical
Method
prophesy a historical event to the
tea and this is something the Muslims
can't deal
with now if they want to say that this
isn't the gospel
that this isn't the NGO that this isn't
what it was then I just want to ask them
[Music]
we